hello everyone
how's everybody doing and welcome to
rational science
today we're going to be talking about a
little property known as
spin but before i get to that i wanted
to
uh talk about a little bit of uh
news i came across this week it's got to
do with my
extinction theory and so i just want to
cover that subject relatively quickly
here
and uh for those of you who are not
familiar
uh my theory says that or
my proposal is not really a theory in
that sense but
uh i'm saying that we're the last humans
on earth okay it all stops here
um don't ask me when it's gonna happen
when the last man's gonna die i can't
tell you if it's gonna be on the first
of may
2025 or anything like that i'm not an
astrologer
i don't claim to be no i'm saying that
the paleontologists have not discovered
the mechanisms
of extinction either for background
extinctions or
mass extinctions and i'm saying that
humans will die in a mass extinction
uh pretty soon and it's going to happen
in the same way it happened to all other
animals
in the past that died in a mass
extinction and that is
just briefly um our economy is going to
fall
to pieces when it does not if but when
it does
money will be no more when money is no
more
trade is no more there will be no trade
the only thing of value to trade will be
food and no one's going to trade
what little they have they're just going
to
eat whatever they have and that's it and
that's the end of man
so whatever foods on the planet at that
moment in time
that's a measure of how much time we
have to live collectively
uh no one will be producing new food
no one will be distributing to the
especially to the city's
new food okay uh so that's in
in general terms i've got a couple
videos on that you can look up
uh those videos and uh become more
more familiarized with the arguments
that i present
anyways the the news i came across
this week had to do with this
organization
government organization united states
known as the cdc
they came up with this bit of news uh
goes like this why the cdc thinks it's
time to prepare for a
possible what zombie apocalypse
okay it says back in the 16th century
french astrologer nostradamus
predicted that there would be a zombie
apocalypse in the year 2021
and now that it's actually 2021 the
centers for disease control and
prevention want to make sure you're
prepared
just in case prepared
prepared for what what are we supposed
to prepare ourselves for is there going
to be a catastrophe
is an asteroid heading our way uh what's
going
on well it's got to do with this and
again it's got to do with the notion
that just about everybody has out there
that mass extinctions were caused by
some kind of catastrophic
disaster climate changes on
is lately on everybody's mouths uh so is
disease because of this cobin
okay but no it's got nothing to do with
that those
not saying none of that is happening all
i'm saying is that's not
got nothing to do with why we're gonna
disappear we're going to disappear when
our economy
falls to pieces okay but here's what
these people are saying you got to
prepare for it says for disaster okay
so um that that's uh that's their um
their argument their their they're going
to be looking at some kind of disaster
what disasters are they talking about
and what are they asking you to prepare
uh
what's this preparation for well here it
is says
you got to prepare food and water and
medical supplies
okay that's what they recommend that you
store
uh at least for some amount of time okay
and uh especially they say especially
water
in here uh
water and first aid supplies
it says noting that although uh here
goes the rest of it
uh here it is you're a goner if a zombie
bites you
you can use these supplies to treat
basic cuts and lacerations that you
might get during what
a tornado or a hurricane
okay so i guess the the the issue here
is that they think there's going to be
or they're cautioning and they say you
know you get you got to have some
supplies in case you know
there is some kind of catastrophe like
we've seen in some
cities uh new orleans comes to mind you
know there was this hurricane this flood
uh okay and uh but i mean we've always
had those
why now is this 2021 any special
just because nostradamus said something
and yeah it's a campaign okay that's all
it is
like you say it's just a joke don't take
it seriously but prepare
maybe there's a different reason for
preparation okay
that they have in mind says preparedness
message out
the better who's uh behind all this well
obviously it's uh
it's the fema your name friendly
neighborhood
fema okay so they said uh you got to be
prepared okay
okay so um yeah uh
prepare for floods uh what is it the
tornadoes
asteroid strike i don't know what else
uh
fires you know uh those are the things
you got to prepare for
um it's kind of strange that they would
bring this
up just when everybody is at home locked
up with
their mouths covered right
kind of strange anyways um
where do i come from from this uh one of
the things that i
want to point out today is that
for those of you who know the theory uh
this is in general terms again i'm gonna
give it a couple uh paint brushes real
quickly here
and uh this is essentially the uh
evolution of man
okay and we've been around maybe 200 300
000 years and what do i mean by that
means that
if today we went back 200 000 or 300
000 years we would be able to have sex
with someone maybe that far back in time
but if you go farther back in time you
would not be able to have reproductive
sex with that
individual so the farther back you go in
time at some point you get to hybrids
and then you get to
know no children at all they don't come
out right because we're just
genetically too different okay so
we're going to make an assumption here
that anywhere between 200 300 000 years
ago
we still were part of um
in other words those people in those
days those were still part of the human
race
because we could have viable children
with them that's the only
criteria in here okay and um
okay so let's assume we've been around
200 000 years
this is what's happened uh with our
economy during that whole time
okay here you see it in a nutshell okay
i'm going to assume 200
000 years we were hunters essentially
okay that's what we used our spears for
we did not hunt lettuce or tomato with
those
we hunted animals but uh about ten
thousand years ago and these numbers are
very general okay so you can
plus or minus five thousand years won't
hurt it at all
uh about ten thousand years ago we
started declining in um
uh globally in hunter hunting and we
went into farming okay we
discovered especially in the neolithic
we discovered how to farm and more and
more individuals went into farming and
left the
jungle okay we formed cities etc
and eventually about 300 200 300 years
ago we
entered the what is known as the
industrial revolution
okay and when we did well we started
making machinery for the farms and
the number of people working the farms
started to decline drastically
what happened these people went to the
cities they started working
in the manufacturing area and from there
we produced
machines that made farming life a lot
easier
and also depleted the country
of people okay because we didn't need
workers there anymore
so gradually that came to our days and
in
the 20th century we had this transition
uh about
in the it was around 79 1980
okay that we really switched over to
services in other words services became
a bigger portion of of the economy of
advanced nations
in europe in the united states primarily
and
we started doing more services at more
people working in services
and more gdp coming out of services
but what i want to point out today is
that there's been a new change
about 10 years ago it's got to do with
the
type with the nature of services okay
for 30 years we had what i what i will
call labor intensive
services and now we change that to what
we could call
self-service you've got a better uh
name for it be my guest okay what am i
talking about well i'm talking about
this
i'm saying the nature of services has
changed or is in the process of changing
okay and uh this is what you get uh
you know you have services such as
barbering
where you know you're doing something
for someone else and you need a person
there
you know you you run a hotel you need
maids that
make the beds uh someone who greets you
at the door etc
airlines you need pilots you need uh
flight attendants
restaurants you need cooks you need bus
boys etc
it's uh still people intensive
okay so those services are a little
different than what we're getting today
and what we're going to be getting today
i think from now on which is everybody
going into
internet type services uh they're going
to be doing uh inner what i call
internet worker
okay so uh someone opens up uh an
account of some kind somewhere someplace
and they're gonna be doing something
some kind of service some maybe
typically geared for entertainment okay
which is absolutely not necessary i mean
it's
meaning life-threatening necessity that
kind of thing like food you need
you know it's uh you absolutely need
food do we need entertainment with us
nice to have
do we need to go on vacation well it'd
be great you know and so on
but it's uh going into kind of like a
leisure world
also into uh commercials you know people
preparing uh
doing a lot of uh computer work both
programming
and setting up websites and so on to
sell more things okay
so uh it's a little different than the
kind of work that where you have a
service where you mow someone's lawn
okay that's like people uh
necessary you need people in there
this is kind of like everybody owns
their own business
okay and uh it's a different type of
service
so i just wanted to point that out to
people out there
uh make whatever you want of it i have
my own
take on this okay what's how that's
gonna affect everything
and i can only leave you with a question
i asked one of my sons
i got three sons and the other day i had
the visit of
my second son and we had a chat about
this
uh quite a quite a long chat and
we had uh i asked him a question because
he said okay so what you know
new generation they say so what uh
yeah there is a silhouette here and this
is what it's
about i asked him the question i said
what
services can you imagine next i mean
we're not going back to manufacturing
we're not going back to agriculture
we're not going to
back to hunter hunting and hunter
gathering
no it's uh if we go forward it's going
to be to services
and the question is what other type of
services
can you imagine let alone implement but
what can you imagine well his answer is
the same answer everybody gives me you
know i said well if i could imagine the
next type of services
you know i'd make some money or whatever
no no that's the wrong answer
it's the wrong answer because you know
jules verne
19th century guy um
he didn't he didn't go to the moon but
he could imagine
going to the moon and he couldn't
imagine you going around the world in 80
days
and now we do it in a lot less than 80
days and so on
he could imagine stuff it was science
fiction for him today it's
technology that we do have
and this is something similar uh it
doesn't mean we have to have it but you
should be able to imagine it
and if you can't imagine it no one else
can imagine it
we won't have it because before we can
have it we have to imagine it
and right now we cannot imagine what
type of service comes next
other than some of the ones that i
mentioned there those were just a
quick uh back of the napkin kind of
brainstorming okay but i'm sure there
you can come up with a lot more
but the point here is the nature of
services have changed
and you know we're in this world where
uh we're doing a lot through the
internet in fact i'm an example
i live off of social security i'm
retired but i mean
here i'm talking about the fact that you
know i do run a channel i
love to do this and that's why i do it i
do it for the fun of it
but a lot of people are getting into it
for the money because they have no other
jobs and there are no other jobs for
them
or not well-paying jobs or they want to
risk it or they want to invest whatever
little
money they have in some kind of uh
in some kind of um
coins maybe bitcoins or stocks or
whatever and they play the market
you know so what is all that it's
speculation it's uh
it's a different type of service okay so
the nature of the services is changing
all i'm asking
i'm asking a fair question i think
please imagine
or try to imagine or see if you can
imagine
the next type of services we will invent
if you cannot invent or come up with a
service
uh well the question is are we gonna
remain with the services we have today
with this structure forever and ever for
the next million years
okay which already gives you an idea
that
uh yeah we're we're getting close to the
end of the line
maybe it's one year maybe it's ten years
but we're getting very close to the end
of the line
okay that's my take on that so let's get
started with this uh
subject matter of today and it's about
this
thing we call spin what the hell is
spin uh quantum property they say
um well it started about uh
what is it 1922. have this these two
fellows
okay and they created a little
experiment
okay remember this is when the atom was
being concocted you had uh niels bohr
and you had uh
rutherford you know they came up with
this planetary atom and so
some people started playing with the
electrons meaning
electricity meaning current okay
and so these two fellows german guys uh
they set up this
uh magnetic uh setup where
they had these magnets going through two
magnets and you can see they're lined up
and pointing in all different directions
that's what they expected under what is
known as classical mechanics okay
and when they tried it with electrons in
others current
they only got two uh versions the
ups and the downs okay so you can see
the difference between the classical
uh if we can call that that we'll call
it classical
classical mechanics where the uh uh
magnus where the tiny magazines are shot
through these two magnets
they're pointing up they're pointing in
the direction in which
they were uh moved by the two big
magnets okay
on the other hand when they ran a
current it was black or white it was up
or down or
you know just two directions
and from that they concocted that there
was something called
spin and you said what do you mean spin
yeah because see when you have a charged
particle that moves
it creates or it takes with it i guess
you could call it uh i don't know how
quantum mechanics really visualizes this
because they talk about it but they
never really visualize it they never can
really
uh make an image of what they're talking
about and so
you have this charged particle it moves
and it carries with it
it's so-called magnetic field so if you
have this electron it's
a charged particle right it's going to
move it creates
this magnetic field and what they're
saying is uh this magnetic field
because of this up these two magnets
can only have two directions one is up
down well
it's up down in both cases but in one
case you get the downs and the others
you get the ups
and and and that's what they found in
the
lab okay so uh
the first problem i'm going to point out
here uh in what gerlack
and stern did
is the notion that quantum mechanics has
the irrational notion that quantum
mechanics has
of what electricity is these people
think
to even to this day that
electricity is the flow of electron
beads
okay and so if each bead carries with it
this
uh magnetic field that's this halo that
surrounds it
which has never been well defined
because when you go look for the word
field it's just a bunch of numbers
that surround uh an object okay
electric field magnetic field
gravitational field
just bunch of numbers somehow those
become physical
objects when they're giving a physical
interpretation
but what's the problem the problem is
the notion of electricity
that quantum mechanics has and that the
entire establishment has
and it is passed down from generation to
generation and nobody ever questions it
okay here it is okay you have the
classical
mechanics which believes it's a flow of
electron beads
from you know going from valence band
valence band from one atom to another
yeah uh it's really not the classical in
in a sense that uh classical mechanics
uh never really had uh this kind of atom
but i'm sure if we bring james maxwell
back to life and we said look uh the
electron
uh is a little bead in the at orbiting
the atom this is what he would come up
with he would say well yeah then
electricity is the flow of electron
beats from atom to atom
what quantum did was get rid of the atom
they got rid of the atom all together
they don't do
use atoms anymore they just flow
electron beads
so uh when they talk about um
electricity going from cathode to anode
they talk about you know electric uh
electron
electron beads little balls going from
one to the other as if you know
uh you have nothing in between in fact
if you evacuate the chamber allegedly
you would think that more beads would
flow because the mean free path
has increased and i'm going to talk a
little bit about that later on because
someone asked
a question about that and i'm going to
address that at the end of the
lecture today okay what's our model well
you can't do electricity without
physical objects
okay you need a physical object what's
the physical object well in the case of
a chamber where you evacuate everything
you still have atoms and molecules
in there okay and what happens these uh
molecules and you have quite a few of
them by the way hundreds of thousands
per centimeter few by the way but you
have
um you have these uh molecules
and they're bound to each other they're
merged
their electron shells under the rope
model are merged
and they spin in situ and it is that
spinning in situ
it's the torsion of that whole what we
call serpentine
that is what we call electricity
okay so we have a different model
in other words of what uh electricity is
okay so let me get back in here
so we start off on the wrong foot
because what happens is quantum
mechanics believes
not only that electricity is the flow of
beads
but when you go even one step back and
say okay what does your atom look like
they have the planetary atom that's the
only way they can explain the
electricity that's the only way they can
explain ionization that's the only way
they can explain quantum jump
they have this little bead going back
and forth
and somehow it goes from energy level to
energy level whatever that is
orbitals whatever those are okay and
when it does so
it releases energy meaning a light
okay uh and what is that that's the
planetary atom
and the only problem with that the only
question that any
mechanic of quantum has to answer very
simple
why doesn't the electron beat fall
negative especially
to the positive nucleus proton why does
it fly away spontaneously
what keeps it rolling around in a circle
and if they can't answer that question
they don't they can't even we're going
to take the micro
microphone away from them they can't
they're not allowed to give their
presentation
because if they cannot answer what keeps
their their model they cannot present a
model that's rational
that's saying well this is the electron
b and it goes back and forth or it flies
out when it does electricity
or when it does ionization tell me what
keeps it bound to the pro
to the proton to begin with why does it
fly away spontaneously why does it fall
to the nucleus
you need to put a physical object
between the electron bead or the proton
otherwise you're doing black magic
and that's what quantum mechanics does
black magic they have no physical
interpretation
for any of their subatomic uh phenomena
or mechanisms and that's why mr bohr all
the way to mr fund and they said no one
understands quantum mechanics of course
they're not going to understand it
because they don't have a
valid model the the discrete model of
particles
is bunk 150 of it
none of it survives okay you can't you
can't explain the invisible
world of mother natures with your uh
planetary model of the atom
or anything below that okay it's all
math none of it is physical
interpretation
okay um
so what is this spin thingy uh this
property this behavior okay this weird
one well if someone asks you to spin the
top i guess you would do
what you see there you grab the top with
a couple of fingers
and just twirl it okay there it is
that's what spin is you look up the
definitions those come from the
wikipedia but you'll find the same ones
everywhere
essentially you know it's not a terribly
scientific word
okay spin a rotation or circular motion
of an object around an internal axis
what is rotation
circular movement of an object around
the center or point of rotation
simple straight forward we're done right
i mean
someone says is the top spinning that's
the notion
uh you're gonna run through your mind
that's what you're gonna think
okay and not these people these people
they have a different notion of
especially when it comes to
uh quantum mechanics but here's the
issue the issue is
the problem is that uh spin
traditional spin classical spin uh
was handled by the mathematicians
that's where the problem is
mathematician is an individual who has
no notion whatsoever of physics
okay and what they do is they try to
apply
math to something that requires no math
math can only describe and that's what
the mathematicians do
they cannot explain okay and that's
where the problem is they have no
physical interpretations of anything
today
because all they do is describe
mathematically
and in this case they created a concept
known as angular momentum
okay you have a linear momentum
something just goes straight and angular
momentum goes around
straightforward okay so they created
angular momentum
but there's two types of angular
momentum okay you have the spin
or angular momentum and you have the
orbit total
angular momentum okay so let's look at
those
let me get rid of this one here um
there it is this is uh a notion
of uh the notion they have of what uh
uh oh i got a reverse
let me get it
now that's better uh this is what is
known as
spin angular momentum okay what is it uh
you look at the
surface think of a point on the surface
for example
and it's going to rotate with respect to
the center okay so you're looking at the
surface
of a single object okay we're talking
about only one object here
and you're going to look at one point on
the surface going to rotate with respect
to the center
straight forward okay but here we have
the orbital one in comparison so that
you can see what the difference is
orbital means that it's more like the
earth going around the sun or the moon
going around the earth
or a kid you know revolving a
ball at the end of a string okay another
object revolves or orbits around the
center of the first one
okay so we have these two notions one is
the surface of one object the other one
is a separate object and it's just going
around
some center for whatever reason a horse
around a post or whatever okay
okay so uh those were the two notions of
angular momentum that these people came
up with
let me clear this a little bit here
okay um and uh what's the problem the
problem is that
quantum mechanics
does not enjoy the particles of quantum
mechanics
do not enjoy these extrinsic
behaviors okay the quantum particles
only have
intrinsic uh behaviors among them
angular momentum
okay and so this is what they're talking
about okay
uh extrinsic property property that an
object
has because of what it's doing
if you're orbiting around something or
you're spinning on your own
you know on yourself around yourself
around your axis
right then that's an in extrinsic
property because you're comparing the
edge against yourself okay
but then you have here uh the intrinsic
property
you know like you have an intrinsic
property it's your mass
how much you weigh or whatever okay and
this is more or less something similar
property of an object has
because of what it is and what they're
saying is spin
as it applies to quantum particles is an
intrinsic property not an
extrinsic one okay so it could be
something
uh with which the electron was born
okay irrespective of what happens
outside its uh
its uh surface okay so that's the notion
we have here
yeah okay um
here we have uh one of the problems that
quantum particles have because of that
it says quantum particles have no
extrinsic properties that can be pinned
down
quantum particles have no comparable
classical behaviors
okay so if you were thinking about uh
a particle rotating around itself or
something along those lines or
even spinning around like in the case of
the electrons spinning
around the proton they say that's not
true
okay they teach you that in high school
but when you get the
the university level they try to kill
that notion completely especially if
you're studying so-called mathematical
physics this follows from the
uncertainty principle what is that well
the more precise you can determine a
particle's position the less you know
about its momentum
okay there you have the little equation
it says you know uh
change in um um what is it
position times change in uh momentum
it's got to be less than that uh value
there
which is uh planck's constant divided by
two
uh that came out of mr uh uh
heisenberg werner heisenberg okay and
the other version is the shorter the
time window the less you know about the
particle's energy
okay and vice versa in other words
quantum particle is totally
unpredictable and you know i like to
make fun of these people
because i think they deserve it okay
every bit of it and so here i show them
mr heisenberg and what he says when the
ball was saying still it doesn't move
that's what his equation is telling you
in physical terms
and when the ball moves it doesn't stand
still no kidding
okay so that's uh that's what uh
heisenberg
got his noble for i hope uh
i hope you understand okay hope you
get the the notion here
okay
okay um so let me get this back up
um this is the problem with quantum
mechanics
or or at least you could call it a
problem i call it a problem but you can
say well this is just a description of
what quantum
believes in what quantum has with what
they do electrons are not solid objects
and we start there okay in fact um
usually it's it's treated like
um a um a
wave a field and they say that's its
natural state until you look at it until
you
measure it until you do something with
it then it
all that collapses suddenly by magic
okay to a particle to a
point particle to a location essentially
okay and now you can measure do whatever
you want
as soon as you take the the i don't know
the measuring tape away or the
scale or whatever you're using to
measure it it goes back to
occupying the whole universe okay so
that's the notion
it's this magical thing that they
essentially cannot explain is
it's nonsense total nonsense uh it's a
point like point point like uh it has no
internal structure
okay what does that mean well how can
something spin if it's got no internal
structure
you see the problem that they run into
because if it's point like
you know what part is spinning with
respect to what
you're not talking about the uh point on
its surface you're pointing
you're you're talking about the fact
that it's it doesn't even have
body there's no structure there okay so
so what are we going to do here you know
this
uh how can you get something to spin
that has no um
no no body okay and uh
spin is a static concept okay in uh
quantum mechanics
it's uh essentially orientation it's a
tilt
it's like i like to describe it as you
make a mark on your top and you spin it
okay
and when it stops if that mark is
pointing upwards
well you call it spin one if it's
pointing in the opposite direction
pointing downwards you call it spin
minus one it's pointing to the side you
pi
maybe you call it spin three halves or
half
or minus one or whatever you give them
numbers that's what they did
they gave numbers to these static
notions essentially okay because it's
when they measure and at that
moment that they measure they say well
this one's got a different uh
spin orientation tilt whatever than that
other one and
we're going to call this one half the
other one minus half remember there are
mathematicians they have to put numbers
to these things
what number are you going to put the
spin so again
it's it's that they're using this word
spin to really mislead you because
every time they talk about spin they
insinuate
and do even more than that they're to
talk about a top
and you say okay i know what electron
spin is yeah you take the top you spin
it that's what electrons doing and
everybody's okay with that except until
when you
put them against the ropes and say okay
hold it what is spin
oh no it's not it's not the same thing
as a top
so what was he talking about for the
last two hours
talking about spin you know for example
they talk about
spin the electrons spinning in two
different magnets of why they attract
each other
and they tell you well it's because the
electron spins what do you mean by that
even if the two electrons spin you know
two balls that spin
how does one top attract another top
because they're spinning in the same
direction
how do they repel if they're spinning in
opposite directions
i mean you gotta explain the mechanism
not say well it's because they spin
spin one what do you mean it's got half
spin or three
three halves plus half makes two or
what what do we do here i mean what is
all that that that doesn't give you a
physical interpretation
of how magnet attracts another but
that's how they use it they use the word
spin in that way
they insinuate they're talking about
spinning
okay so they have these different uh
weird spins
okay and what do i mean by that well
here you get a difference between for
example fermions and bosons
the bozos okay as i call them
good name for them fermions uh electron
muon
neutrinos they have half spins okay
which are
half integer multiples of planck's
constant divided by
two pi okay and then you have the bosons
uh which are the photons gluons w's and
z's the weak forces there okay
and they have inner spins okay
and fermions obey paulie's exclusion
principle
okay which means two fermions cannot
exist in the same state
whereas bosons can congregate in the
same state
okay so this is how they separate these
they
give these properties these mathematical
properties
these descriptions to all these
particles okay and that's their world
uh what's it got to do with spin i don't
know beats me
okay really it doesn't have to do with
spinning like spinning of a top
get it okay so how do they infer these
things
okay you say i mean if if it's not
spinning it's not spinning what is it
and how do they come up with all this
stuff well quantum spin is like the spin
of a planet okay in that
it gives a particle angular momentum and
a tiny magnetic field called a magnetic
moment
okay so we have this magnetic this
little magnet because that's what they
think an electron is a little
magnet whatever a magnet is because they
don't even know what a magnet is okay
it's got this magnetic field around
itself this halo okay
and what happens uh however because
of calculated particle sizes okay
you know you look at the what the
diameter of the radius
of one of these particle is one once
they calculated okay
the surfaces of these charged particles
would have to move
faster than light the surface right if
it
if it were spinning to produce the
measured magnetic moments
okay so imagine the top okay and it's
going to spin
here wouldn't okay
okay imagine a tom you look at the
surface here the the edge
okay what happens you think of it
spinning
but the smaller you make it okay the
smaller you make it
the faster the uh the um
the the point on the outside on the
surface
is going to go around when you get to
these particles which
are measured or calculated to be very
very very very very
small at some point you exceed the speed
of light
of rotation the the little edge whatever
particle you imagine being there
is spinning faster than the speed of
light
and that's why they say these particles
cannot spin
in a classical way
okay in other words in a rational way
that's what classical means
classical means rational okay because in
the old days they were
still trying to explain these things in
a rational manner we've forgotten about
all that
uh when quantum and relativity came
along they started
uh giving irrational physical
interpretations
okay and here's an example of uh
calculation out there i'll just briefly
go through it don't get scared i'm not
gonna do
any math not interested in that uh you
get the radius
of an electron for example 10 to the
minus 13 centimeters that's a calculated
value it's an approximate value
of what they think the radius is and you
look at the mass 9 times 10 to the
minus 31 okay kilograms okay
and to calculate the radius there you
have the little equation and you can see
there's that little c which is three
hundred thousand kilometers per second
okay what happens uh
that to get an angular momentum of uh
bar h bar divided by two which is
uh planck's constant variation of it
with
sublumin subliminal rotation speeds the
electron radius must be greater than
what
the compton radius of the electron which
uh calculated to be 10 to the
minus 11 centimeter remember when the
exponent
is smaller that particle is bigger
okay so if you get to minus 11 minus 10
minus 9 minus 8
the atom is getting the electron is
getting bigger bigger and bigger
okay and they know that the electron
can't be that big
it's got to be smaller smaller smaller
well if you make it smaller
all you're doing is making that little
point on the surface of the electron
going faster and faster and faster
and at some point again you exceed the
speed of light and so they say that's
because they
that's how they figured out that the
spin
of a subatomic particle such as an
electron is not the typical spin
of um of classical mechanics of a top
spin
okay that's probably the best way to put
it spinning over top
electron doesn't spin like a top okay
okay
so um here is uh
the conclusion from quantum mechanics
essentially
why the electron cannot spin like a top
okay
mass would have to rotate faster light
okay the mass of the electron
the charge because remember charge is a
physical entity according to
quantum mechanics not a concept as it is
in rational science charge would have to
also rotate faster than light that means
that whole
field that's that halo that surrounds
the electron
uh that's got to be spinning also faster
at night because of these calculations
and then the ratio of the electrons
magnetic moment to its angular momentum
is off by a factor of two okay so if
they do the calculations that's what
they end up with they said then it
cannot be spinning
therefore the electrons don't spin and
uh they don't orbit either meaning but
if they don't orbit it means that
they're not orbiting the proton
which is the model that niels bohr and
rutherford essentially
came up with so if not doing that if
it's not orbiting
what the hell is this electricity that's
flowing
which is the electrons moving from
valence band to valence band
okay so all that falls apart
it falls apart because we have a problem
in the
in the model of the atom they cannot
conceptualize their own atom they don't
have
any idea today what an electron looks
like they said they've taken pictures of
the atom
uh the swedish group there that i showed
the other day
they filmed the electron they know
everything about it but then when you
put them against the wall they say we
don't we don't know what it looks like
what do you mean you took a picture of
it you interviewed it you know
you had all this stuff they put them on
tv and then they said we don't know what
it looks like
great yeah and what was that that i saw
on tv you know
okay here are my conclusions on this uh
electron spin spin electron especially
the the electron remember
it's not the only particle that's
alleged to spin again bosons and uh
all fermions etc all these also have
spin
okay where my conclusions these are mine
okay quantum mechanics uh electron
is not a particle not a particle in the
traditional sense of a particle okay
corpuscle grain of sand a speck of dust
etc you know i'm talking about a real
particle
it's nothing like that in fact it's not
a particle at all because
allegedly it only becomes a particle or
condenses to a pinpoint
only when you measure or see it or touch
it or whatever
as long as you don't look they say
you know electron has this mind of its
own as long as you don't look
it's spread out and it's a field
a vibrating field whatever field is what
is it a three-dimensional
fishnet like uh special uh
like uh general relativity a set has its
space time
you know this uh net
this uh canvas is that what it is
the vibration of a point in space time
is that what it is
a lot of people imagine it that way
anyways electron has no body
okay so there is no radius
what radius are you going to talk about
if you got nothing in front of you
no body means space empty space that's
what it is
and that's what they're saying the
electron is essentially electrons don't
orbit the proton
okay because they don't orbit anything
but if they don't orbit do they flow
from
uh atom to atom then we have a problem
there as well because then if they don't
orbit
what is this electricity stuff the flow
of electron beams from atom to atom is
that what
electricity is or is it like i showed
under the rope model a torsion of a
bunch of
merged shell electron shells from
different atoms and molecules okay so
that's
probably a better model okay electron
doesn't spin on its axis
okay so spin is a property uh the
mathematicians invented and misnamed
to describe an unexplained mechanism
that makes
electrons behave as magnets
that's what spin is it's just something
they
invented to talk about the magnetic
properties
of an electron and they don't know what
a magnet is because to this day no one
can tell you
in quantum mechanics how a magnet
attracts another you know they cannot
explain
forget about the quantum world they
cannot explain this how uh
here we have two magnets okay and they
cannot explain that
something as simple as that i mean how
difficult can this be
let me get this out of here a second
here
i mean how difficult can this be here
you have two magnets
okay we put them together and they stick
uh there's two objects two two little
magnets
there's something in here they call
magnetic field
whatever field is okay and
somebody probably says this magic and to
this day no one can explain this
if they cannot explain this how are they
going to explain something they don't
see
such as the magnetic moment of an
electron
i mean they had to start here you cannot
explain this the attraction how this
attracts that
physically much less are you gonna talk
about something you cannot see that has
the same properties
okay so this is what they have to
explain very simple
and of course mathematicians has no idea
what physics is about that's why all
these mathematical physicists so-called
physicists
all they do is study math but they have
no idea
of the physical world they cannot
explain the real
world in other words they cannot give a
physical interpretation to the real
world
because they're uh using the right
measure they're using the
quantum atom okay and that's the
planetary atom
and of course you cannot explain
anything with that atom and yeah there's
got to be something in here
and and that something is a physical
object it's an
object that's in there that can we
cannot touch or
see but as james maxwell said and
also uh mr faraday you know there's
matter in motion there's some exotic
matter in motion that makes
up what we call a field all those lines
of force
uh as mr faraday said there's something
physical in there and he was right there
is something physical
the threads of the rope
we have threads in there each one of
those little
lines is a thread it's known as a thread
a physical object that's sweeping around
and all those threads are creating the
so-called that's what we call the
magnetic field
and yeah we can explain with that how
attraction and repulsion
you know if they're they're hitting
against each other the threads they push
each other away you have repulsion
you turn with the magnets around 100
degrees 180 degrees
and now they're both going in the same
direction and when one comes down the
other one comes up and now you have
attraction very simple mechanism baby
stuff kindergarten stuff
to understand it whether you believe it
or not is
not a question not it doesn't concern
science
okay and so yeah uh when they get into
the spin stuff they don't know what
they're talking about because
they're measuring essentially what
they're doing under the rope model
what you have is a membrane and that's
what the electron is a membrane
and the membrane is made out of the
threads itself
okay and those threads are spinning in
situ all around
uh like mr the broly said a guy who said
that
electrons behave as waves as well and so
they're spinning in situ
all around the electron shell it because
they make up the electron shell they
weave the electron shell
and if this one's going to this one on
this side let's see if we get it in here
this one i better do it with a ball
maybe that's the best way to do it
so if this little piece here this uh
this thread here is moving in this
direction
guess what this one's moving well it's
uh moving the opposite direction they
have to be
in opposite sides and now we can find
out why
paulie's exclusion principle is true
because one side had better be opposite
the other side
okay mother nature doesn't understand
half spins and
minus spins or zero spins mother nature
understands clockwise and
counterclockwise and that's what the
thread is doing one side is clockwise
the other side had
better had better be counterclockwise
and now we have paulie's exclusion
principle there
we need not use this word spin
and insinuate that there is a spinning
something in there uh which is not spin
which is an
orientation or a tilt to which they
assign a number
and with which they cannot give a
physical interpretation to
absolutely any phenomenon out there
okay with that i'm gonna go into the
questions we had quite a few uh
questions this time uh so let's get on
with that
one fellow says ass says uh why are you
ignoring
responses uh it's not that i ignore
responses it's sometimes we can't get to
all the questions
if uh if i missed your question
no problem just ask it again the next
time and uh
we'll see if we'll put it on usually i
try to get the best questions
sometimes i just go through and pick up
first come first serve and that's what i
put on there okay
so uh nothing personal we miss your
question we'll
address it here again and so i'm gonna
address this gentleman's uh questions
because he raised some valid issues and
i'd like to answer these issues i'd like
to tackle
tackle the bull by the horns you know
okay
uh light doesn't slow down he says
no light doesn't slow down so he says
i've used three search
earned engines and everything i find
says light slows down yeah you found
them all
for sure from mathematical physics not
not from rational science okay
and speeds back up immediately uh
entering and leaving a medium such as a
prism or water
okay that's because they have you have
the notion
that uh light is made of particles or
waves
one-way particles one-way waves
and here we're talking about a rope that
is stretched
from atom to atom it's talked
and it's taught because uh the
speed of light is a measure of that
tension
okay and here you can see uh that
c equals frequency times wavelength is
the equation
of a rope it's the so-called wave
equation no it's the rope
equation only a rope can imitate that
equation
there is no other object elongated
object that can do that
and why because you take any rope very
simple
okay take a rope the more you torque it
okay see if i can torque it a little bit
got my strength today
okay and the more you torque it the more
links you have
and the shorter each link frequency
times wavelength
for a given length of rope and the more
you untorque it
okay the links become longer
and you have fewer links frequency times
weight
very simple that's the equation of a
rope and so what happens when you
have light going into a prism there's
nothing really going in there what you
have is torsion
of all the ropes that are in the room
everything's torquing there some you can
see some you cannot some come in the
visible range some do not and what
happens you shine white light
on a prism it's inside it you have this
refraction you have
one atom connected to another atom that
same atom is connected to a second atom
that same atom is connected to a third
atom and so on down the line
two gazillions of atoms and so you have
a different path
and uh what you have there is different
um pumping speeds of each one of these
atoms that
are relaying the signal uh that
came in they're relaying it that's what
it is and what happens is because of
that
the ropes get longer and between
different sets of atoms and what you see
there is again what you see is just the
difference in
rope uh in the length lengths of these
ropes that's all it is okay so what you
have is that red one
has longer links than the blue one at
the bottom that's all it is all you did
was change frequency
in exchange for wavelength the speed of
light remains the same
always light always travels at the same
speed through
any medium what the mathematicians did
to get over that is what i used in the
semiconductor industry which is known as
refractive index
which is a ptolemaic solution
to what light really does and that is
they said well you know
when it goes through glass it goes
slower like in the case of silicon
dioxide
travels at around 1.45 um
in other words you have to divide the
speed of light by 1.45 which is
rounding off 150 uh and that gives you
two instead of 300 000 kilometers per
second gives you 200 000 kilometers per
second
and that's allegedly the speed of light
through glass
through silicon dioxide okay
and that's an artificial human
type explanation for what mother nature
does it's a ptolemaic explanation
now light always travels at 300 000
kilometers per second because the
tension between any two atoms is always
the same
all that changes is frequency in
exchange for wavelength
okay the links become shorter or longer
that's it that's what color is color is
just a different
length of of links what they call
wavelength
okay so we call it length length okay so
no the
light doesn't never change the speed
okay so
uh just wanna reinforce that okay
whether you believe it or not
your problem all i'm telling you is we
have a different explanation for
the speed of light light always travels
at sea
through denser medium through uh
lighter medium it doesn't matter through
through
vacuum through whatever i don't care if
it travels through walls
light always travels at the same speed
between any two atoms
because the only thing that changes is
the length length
and what do we mean by speed it means
that if you send a signal for example
well we have the case of the lunar range
experiment where uh they uh the
moon is about approximately a little
over uh
one light second away from us okay and
they have this
uh laser that they point at the
um mirror over there that they the
astronauts put in there
i think the russians also put one on the
moon and they check to see if the moon
is getting closer or farther away
and they measure that through the
through the laser
because uh they expect uh light to take
one second ago one second to come a
little over so it's a little over two
seconds round trip
and you cannot explain that with quantum
mechanics or general relativity
why because you know the moon moved
that's one issue the other issue is that
if if you're going to hit that mirror
the lunar ranger arranging
apparatus they put on the moon you gotta
shoot it where the moon's gonna be in
one second
because it's gonna take one second for
your beam to get reached the moon
so you don't shoot it at the at the
mirror you're gonna shoot it
one second away and the moon travels at
30
kilometers around uh sorry one kilometer
per second
around the earth so you gotta
put it one kilometer away that's where
these people would have to
shoot it in order to hit the the mirror
and obviously that's not the case they
shoot it directly at the mirror and they
have no problem finding them here it's
not like they shoot it over there you
know
left field because they say well in one
second the moon's gonna be over there so
we better
shoot our laser over there no that's not
the way it works they shoot it directly
in the mirror because
the mirror is connected by ropes
directly to your
laser pointer or whatever they're using
whatever laser beam they're using
they're connected the atom over there is
connected by
rope by a rope to the atom over here and
so the moon can go anywhere it wants
uh you know the light's gonna travel
along that same rope and it's gonna find
the moon
anywhere even if the moon goes to the
other side of the universe
the laser is going to find it okay
because it travels along a rope that is
connecting the moon to us
or one of the roads gazillions of ropes
okay
so yeah that's the notion of the speed
of light always travels at the same
speed okay here's another
issue this gentleman raised and again
if i don't answer your question you can
raise it again no problem
electricity doesn't flow in a vacuum
yeah it doesn't
and he says of course electricity works
in a vacuum
what now vacuum tubes don't exist
[Laughter]
yeah vacuum tubes exist and there you
have several types of vacuum
tubes okay uh the one in the center
up there that's a vacuum tube from the
days of the radio you know
this is a modern one anyways we don't
make those anymore because
at least we don't make them for uh for
what we used to use
in the past for radios but we use lamps
uh bolts right we have the uh
what is the plasma ball
and we also have fluorescent tubes other
than the fluorescent tubes all the
others
uh essentially heat something
a physical object okay so it's not like
um
the uh the elec
electricity is flowing through the
vacuum really it's just
glowing along the the wire in there okay
okay but the fluorescent tube is a
little different okay so uh
yeah but what i want to show you here is
the following okay
first of all nobody can answer these
questions
uh in the world today here you have the
people at the stack exchange
stack exchange is usually visited by
so-called phds
or or people who are getting their
masters or whatever these are
only university people are allowed to
essentially put their
comments there everybody else is
excluded and of course they
told the party line okay and so the
question was asked over there
and these are the answers that people
get that people give you
and you can see there's very little
uniform
very little uniformity in the answers
these people give you
these are the answers okay let me move
it over here oh
okay these are the answers the stack
exchange
give can electricity flow through a
vacuum that's the question okay
and i say that you know physics stack
has changed a question and answer
site for active researchers academics
and students of physics okay so this is
high level stuff okay you only get the i
mean they won't allow anybody else
in there okay and the vacuum is and
not a conductor these are the answers
people gave okay
the vacuum is not a conductor at all
okay
good another guy says yes it is still a
conductor
because it allows the flow of current
i know we should get them together and
find out you know
put gloves on them and fight against
each other
electricity is a flow of electrons okay
what do we say that electricity is not a
floral electron these guys say it is
okay
that's what they learn by rote okay
party line electrons can flow across
a vacuum so now we forget about the atom
now we have just electrons flowing
through the vacuum that's the notion
that is being taught
to all these people who go to college
who get phds
okay over a long range is that you need
a force to get the electrons to travel
across the vacuum
but this guy is saying that you need
high enough voltage
a big push big potential right
to get those electrons to bridge that
you know that gap that nothingness but
the electrons will flow you just got to
push them hard enough
that's what that's the notion that
quantum mechanics
is teaching all these so-called phds
that graduate okay uh and the other guy
said no
because vacuum is not a material object
like that the word conducted was meant
for material
bodies good some people are smart but
but see they don't agree and the other
guy says a vacuum
is the absence of atmosphere and is a
neutral force
offering neither resistance nor
conductiveness to proton electron flow
what have we learned does electricity
flow through vacuum or not
they cannot tell you they don't know
especially the
so-called physicists the mathematical
physics they have no clue whatsoever
these people are babes in in the woods
they have no
idea whatsoever whether electricity
flows through a vacuum or not they're
just giving you their their opinion
right okay uh
just want to point out so that uh you
can cut
corners here and go directly to what i
answered okay
put it over here uh i did this in quora
so you can find there's the link you
can't click on it but
you can just copy it and look for it can
electricity flow through a vacuum i
answered the question over there a while
back
and you can find my answer there with
all the links okay i usually give full
answers to these questions okay so you
can find it there
and so what is my take on this okay here
uh
what i want to show is really what what
vacuum is people don't know what vacuum
is
especially all these mathematical
physicists they have no idea what vacuum
is
they never work with vacuum never did
anything with vacuum
even though people who work at the lhc
large hadron collider over there in
cern in switzerland you know
they really have no idea what vacuum is
they they talk about different
levels of vacuum so i thought i'd make a
little chart
okay for your enjoyment for your benefit
for your education okay so here it is
just to give you a snapshot
so that you can put everything within
the proper context okay here it is okay
and uh it goes like this the vacuum
tubes this fellow talked about
well that's close to atmospheric
pressure
why because they evacuate they evacuate
the tube but then they fill it back up
with some kind of inert gas such as
argon or it could be nitrogen
they just fill it back with with a gas
okay and usually it's done to protect
the uh
the filament okay so it doesn't burn uh
so quickly
okay so but you can see they're almost
close to the the number one there and
the number one represents
atmospheric pressure okay and i put the
tube
uh to the right but it really falls in
line with the other three okay
i put it to the side because i couldn't
fit it in there okay
uh here you have the space power
facility that's in ohio
and you can see it's in the 10 to the
minus 5 to the
10 to the minus 6 torr range whatever
that means to you is not important and
the value
i'm just saying that you can see it's
much higher vacuum
or much lower pressure if you want to
think of it that way
then what you see in the uh these tubes
okay i worked in semiconductor i worked
in
in that specific area the implant area i
also worked with um
sputtering what is known as sputtering
which also requires a
vacuum okay and we worked in the 5 to
the minus 7 range
10 to the minus 7 range okay so the
orange there
is where you would find semiconductor
processing
the gray areas where you find a space
power facility
why did i mention that one well because
that's where astronauts are trained
they're trained at 10 to the minus six
and you say well why a 10 to the minus
six why not
i mean if you go to the moon it's 10 to
the minus 11 torr
and the solar wind is in the 10 to the
minus 12 10 to the minus 13 torr there's
it's almost what you could call from our
point of view pure vacuum
which is not okay you still have like
200 000 or 80 000
particles there per centimeter cubed
okay
but why don't they train these
astronauts at 10 to the minus 11 if
that's what they're going to find out
there
well because it makes no difference
between 10 to the minus 6 and 10 to the
minus
11 torr as far as pressure or vacuum
is concerned why did they choose 10 to
the minus 6 because at that point there
is no electricity
all you get if anything is zapping you
get what is known as arcing
okay but you cannot have a constant
current
at uh 10 to the minus seven ten to the
minus eight ten to the minus
nine there is no electricity that's why
the astronauts don't get zapped
when they go out into space or to the
moon or to whatever
and again i'm talking to people who i
hope are not flat earthers okay
who people who believe that yeah we did
go to the moon
if you go to the moon you get 10 to the
minus 11 but it doesn't but you're not
going to get zapped by electricity
because there is no
electricity like the electrical electric
universe believes
out there in space okay you don't get
zapped
but that's what a lot of people believe
that you know electricity can flow
through the vacuum
that's not true first of all because
electricity is not the flow of electron
beads
second because it's not the flow of
electron beads without atoms which is
what quantum does which is what quantum
believes and
has concluded after a hundred years of
nonsense
and then and then you can
i mean and here's well here's the punch
line this is what i want to show
hope it's this one yeah here you have uh
the classical on top you can call it
classical uh
electricity uh when i put the atom i
call it classical that's
the only thing and then you have the uh
quantum version which is just electron
beads without any atoms
okay so supposedly supposedly right
if i were to remove all the material
from that chamber in other words if i
were to remove
have a perfect vacuum absolutely no
atoms whatsoever i use
god's magic wand no more particles in
lyrics
then the flow of electron beads
should increase because the mean free
path
has increased i hope you understand it
here
and here i i illustrated that so you see
what i'm talking about okay
here it is okay which do you think would
have
a higher mean free path the one on the
top
where you have absolutely uh no material
it's pure vacuum
100 vacuum no no atoms in there
or do you think the electrons would have
a tougher time
going from cathode to anode on the
bottom one
where you have all those particles
getting in the way of the flow of
electrons
which do you think would show more
electric
current okay that's the question
because if if i remove
more and more and more and ever more
atoms from the chamber if i get rid of
all the water i get rid of all the air i
get rid of
any of the stuff that's on the walls or
in the ambient in there
i have fewer atoms fewer and fewer atoms
the electron current should increase if
electricity is the flow of electron
beads from cathode to anode
very simple you have a greater mean
theory path
on the upper right than you have on the
lower right okay
that's the argument so uh
no uh we don't have electricity flowing
through the vacuum
pure vacuum okay i'm talking about pure
vacuum
100 vacuum all vacuum nothing in the way
of electron beads electron beads won't
flow in other words you don't
have electricity in a pure vacuum
because in that sense it's what these
other guys said the vacuum
is an insulator not a conductor but a
lot of people don't understand that
because they never
first of all they never worked in the
industry so they have no idea
about electricity in its relation to
vacuum
but the reason we we implant what is
known as implant
phosphorus and boron into into
semiconductor devices to give them
electrical characteristics is
uh the reason we work at the uh
five to the five to the minus seven
torr range is because at that point you
have
essentially a clean um you don't have
any arcing you don't have any
uh electricity in the ambient so you can
just uh
send the so-called ions right because
that's what we implant we implant
phosphorus and boron ions
you can send them in they're not going
to collide against anything or so-called
anything i mean
you got very little to collide against
because you have
essentially a clean environment the more
junk there is in there
the more electricity you get the more
current you have the
the more garbage you have in there and
the less
you can implant uh something clean into
your wafer
okay so no there is no current at high
vacuum
okay get that through your thick skulls
yeah yeah and i'll put my hand in the
fire just against anyone out there
who works in the industry and they'll
tell you don't have current
at high vacuum yet don't have turn that
high vacuum
that's why the electric universe is 150
percent
nonsense these people say that
everything out there is run with
electricity
these people are demented they have no
clue whatsoever
okay so that's the way it is simply is
you can take this to the bank
believe me there is no current
at high vacuum period
and that's why the astronauts are
trained at -6 because at that point
that's when you have essentially no
current
so they know they won't be zapped at -6
okay so that's part of the reason that
the johnson space center was designed
that way
to to train uh astronauts at low vacuum
low enough vacuum that it won't affect
won't change anything if you get even
higher vacuum like you know you get
-6 torr it doesn't matter if you train
at minus six or minus eleven it won't
make a bit of a difference as far as
vacuum is concerned
but the issue there is that you wanna
make sure that you don't get zapped by
electricity
that's part of the issue okay uh another
issue this uh same gentleman raised i
says plasma isn't an object no no a
plasma
only the electric universe believes that
uh plasma is an object
now it's not a thing plasma is not a
thing you heard it from me okay
let me repeat it just in case you say he
made a mistake no no plasma
is not a thing okay so i repeat that
plasma which we use in television blah
blah blah blah blah
lightning the aurora and some flames
consist of plasma this is an
object the fourth state of the fourth
state of matter i like that one i'm
going to get to that one
material thing that can be seen and
touched that has three dimensional
properties which has weight in a
three-dimensional locational
environment even by your definition an
object is that which has shape plasma is
an object
no no no no no let's get first to the
fourth state i love that the fourth
state
i thought it was 50 states but you know
i guess this guy
was there before the revolution right so
he was still with a fourth state
okay here it is here's the fourth state
issue okay let's get that over with
okay hopefully it's not the fourth state
because four state
is a category it's like talking about
furniture
plants or planes uh planes meaning uh
you know like in
geometry or solids okay is
a plane a physical object no a plane is
a category
of geometric uh objects are is the word
plant
uh a physical object no it's a it's a
category
so it's furniture you know you can say a
table is
a physical object you can't say that
furniture is a physical
object and that's the that's the issue
with the four
state you can't say that if for state is
just one of the fourth
uh categories solids liquids gases and
what plasmas
okay then if it's a four state it's a
category you can't say that plasma is a
physical object
because solids is not a physical object
and planes is not a physical object
liquids and gases
uh plural right is not a physical object
these are categories
okay a category is not a physical object
and so either plasma is a fourth state
okay meaning it's a category
or it's a material thing can't be both
so it's a thing or it's a fourth state
and of course there is a condition of
matter okay it's an adjective a
qualifier a modifier of a noun
okay okay so that's my first argument uh
the fourth state and people don't
understand language that's why they make
these errors the
electric universe especially makes this
error all the time that's the fourth
state
of matter on the one hand then they say
yeah i'm gonna move the plasma i'm gonna
shake it i'm gonna make it vibrate or
whatever
no or the sun is made of plasma or
whatever
okay uh what's the other issue let's
address this other issue that this
gentleman
raised okay and here it is uh
an object is not that which you can see
or touch so it doesn't matter if you can
see it or touch it as you said a
material thing that can be seen and
touched
doesn't matter that's not the definition
of an object okay
object is that which has shape not that
which you can see or touch not all
objects can be seen
or touched you can't see the air for
sure and you can't touch a tri bar
okay you can touch the paper or the uh
ink but you can't touch a tri bar or a
circle or whatever
you can't touch the superman i'm i'm
thinking of or the table i'm thinking of
either okay and hopefully the word table
refers to an object always
so the word table is always an object
whether it's the one out there the one i
can touch or the one that i'm imagining
which i cannot
touch so touch is not
a synonym of objects not a definition
for the word object
it's shape shape is uni only universal
property all
objects have and if you can see or touch
it yes you are referring to an object so
it does work the other way around if you
can see and touch it
for sure you're talking about or you're
referring to an object all that is seen
and touched
or touched is an object does this make a
spirit
an object now because you say i touch
the spirit
so he's an object well did you touch a
spirit what do you mean by spirit
okay and you know
we get down to what it is that you talk
you're talking about
so the fact that you see or touch the
the maybe what you touch was the wall
maybe touch the curtain and you said i
touched the spirit
well no you touched the curtain you
didn't touch the spirit
but you thought you touched the spirit
and you talk in terms of spirit
when spirit is not a physical object so
remember
we got to keep those contexts in mind
okay
and then the other issue is that um no
objects are not three-dimensional
objects can be two-dimensional or
three-dimensional
and again the the table i'm imagining is
two-dimensional
okay and so uh you can't touch it
it's not 3d it's just uh or even the
the face of superman
the one i have in my mind it's
two-dimensional it's just a
uh what is it like a caricature of
superman
and so if i can imagine the shape of the
face of subaru with his whole body
in two dimensions uh that's an object
because it has shape it has
the requirement of the definition meets
the requirement of the definition which
is shape
and can i touch is it 3d no
so touch 3d none of those define the
word object
okay and that's where the problem is uh
people confuse 3d
because they're trying to introduce
existence the word exists
together with the word object problem
that mr
kant imminently kent and mr david hume
had they couldn't distinguish between
object and exist they thought that an
object is that which exists that they're
synonyms and they're not
okay and everybody that came after made
the same error
all the way to mr sartre and uh aimrand
and all the rest of them
okay there you have a two-dimensional
object you have
two of them in fact you have one which
is a tree and the other one which is a
square
they have shape so they qualify under
the definition of object
do they exist well not the
two-dimensional ones
physics works with three with uh
not only with three-dimensional objects
but objects that exist
uh physics doesn't work with cubes cube
is conceptually you know a
three-dimensional
object it's defined as such so when we
point we
we look at a two-dimensional
representation of a cube
but you're supposed to give it you know
projection and think of it in 3d same
with a cylinder same with a pyramid
but physics doesn't work with 3d objects
of that nature okay even superman he can
be 3d for all we care
you can imagine him as 3d you can shade
him up and think of him even though he's
in a two-dimensional
uh platform or background
you know you can think of superman as a
3d
object but it's a 3d object that doesn't
concern physics because it's an object
that doesn't exist
and physics only works with 3d objects
that
exist certainly it doesn't work with 2d
objects
like those two there does it work with
trees well with the ones that exist yes
we can talk about a tree shaking and
because the wind pushed it or aside we
can talk about that in physics we cannot
talk about
that one there which is a
two-dimensional drawing or picture or
snapshot of a
tree that one doesn't concern physics
but it's still an object because it has
shape it meets the definition of shape
physics works only with objects that
exist
those are all 3d physics does not work
with 3d objects that don't exist
imaginary ones like the 3d table i'm
imagining
and it doesn't work with 2d objects okay
so that's the issue the issue is we have
to separate the word object from the
word
exist and people have a hard time with
that
it takes two years for them to separate
those two words object from exist
one guy talks about and
a fly says what side of the square is
the fly on
that's an issue of existence so
it's brushed aside completely it means
you don't understand squat
okay no whether the fly
3d fly is on one side of the uh square
or not that's an issue of existence not
an issue of
object right now we're in the issue of
object we're trying to define the word
object for the purposes of physics
and for the first verses of science and
it's that which has shape
which is the only property all objects
it's a universal property of all objects
okay
and do we work with all of them no we
only work with
those that exist those that have
location objects that have location
that's what existence has to do with
okay
and uh so here we finish up with this
uh plasma
okay that's what plasma is okay what is
plasma
a wave field all these are just concepts
and concepts don't have shape there is
no concept that has shape
okay shadow is a concept what the shadow
mean it means
blocked light black light is not a
physical object
so no shadow does not have shape and you
say well
what about what am i pointing to well
you're pointing to the floor that's what
you're pointing to
no no that's my shadow no no the shadow
is blocked light
and that shadow is not standalone
because it goes all the way to your
feet and i can't separate the shadow
from your feet so you're part of the
shadow or verse vice verse of the
shadows part of you
but as soon as we put you out into space
the shadow disappears and you're still
there
okay what is plasma plasma is ionized
ionized ionized ionized
gas ionized means you're going to do
something to the gas
you're going to do something to the gas
plasma is not a standalone object
do you see anything standing alone in
there it looks like everything is moving
you have these atoms and their electrons
are moving around because they've been
ionized okay so plasma is a dynamic
concept because it doesn't stand still
any more than a running boy is not a
physical
object a boy is an object but not a
running boy
a fly is a let's use another example
because that's a bad word um
an eagle is an object not a flying eagle
a kangaroo is an object not a flying not
a jumping kangaroo
okay and plasma is a jumping kangaroo
plasma is never standing still
why because it has to be ionized by
definition
the definition of the word plasma is
ionized ed
ionized gas means you're going to do
something to the gas
you need two frames in the movie and
here i synthesize it so that
even the dumbest people can understand
it
uh where is it do i have it oh yeah
because it's the next issue
this uh individual also said
what is a dynamic concept
okay so let's find out what a dynamic
concept is and why
plasma is a dynamic concept not a
physical object okay here it is
okay here we have it a concept a word
that invokes or embodies two objects
that's the first thing we have to
mention
and it's the short version it continues
it's a word invokes and bodies two
objects or two words treated as
objects like in the case of space in the
majority of cases
okay anyways what's a static concept a
relation involving
objects that don't move all those words
are static concepts distance location
exists standing
position pointing facing straight
dimension
coordinate angle all those are static
concepts there's nothing
moving when you say angle angle is not
what
what it is in the religion of
mathematics where they
move one line with respect to another
now angle you point to in in rational
science
angle is when it's done when you're done
moving that other
stick that's when you finish that's when
what we call an angle
not when you're moving it okay and same
with parallel parallel is not two lines
that go off to infinity and you go chase
them and find out if i mean if they go
to infinity
uh we never we're never gonna find out
if the two lines are parallel
no parallel means equidistant lines
that's what parallel is
it's not what it is in the religion of
mathematics where they go out and they
say
well go find out go to the infinity and
find out if those two lines meet
okay uh what is a dynamic concept what's
a relation
involving motion in other words all
mathematical concepts essentially are
especially equations etc all those are
a dynamic concept what is an equation it
describes
motion running jumping energy mass field
wave time etcetera etcetera vector
uh vortex you know the the tornado
tornado is not a physical object tornado
is a concept a dynamic concept the
object is air
gas or whatever you want to call it uh
vortex means it's
in motion and that's what plasma is
plasma is something
in motion vortex is something in motion
electricity is something in motion there
is no physical
object called electricity and uh
the bean brains of the of the electric
universe say well
why don't you stick your fingers into
the outlet and find out if it's a
physical object
well that's not how we do it in in
science okay we don't we don't stick our
fingers
in the outlet to find out if electricity
is a physical object because touch has
nothing to do
or see has anything to do with object
object is that which has shape does
electricity have shape
if it doesn't it's not an object very
simple besides the
point that uh electricity is a dynamic
concept there's something in motion in
there
and as long as you have motion you have
concepts yeah
especially dynamic concepts okay
okay uh here's a handy way of um
looking at dynamic and static concept
hopefully this will
help you put in the right context okay
let me put it over here
okay static concept you can think of is
two
objects in a single frame of the movie
you look at a single frame make it as
small as you want
i don't care when you have a single
frame
snapshot picture photograph whatever you
want to call it
drawing statue
if you have two objects that's a concept
because that's the definition of the
word concept
two two uh a word that invokes or
embodies
two objects so that's a concept in this
case example distance
okay distance requires two objects you
have one point to another
you can't have distance without two
objects okay
dynamic concept you need two frames
because you're talking about motion
motion is what two
or more locations of an object okay
so so now you in that case it's the moon
going around the earth or you see two
locations of the moon
that's uh what we call orbit
dynamic concept so you need to
understand the difference between a
dynamic consonant
and a static concept and and plasma is a
static
is a dynamic concept what is the object
the object is the atom right even
even under the uh quantum version or the
electric universe
version what what is plasma plasma means
that you have an
atom and you're going to strip away
let's we'll go with that and
you can also put one in but you strip
away the electron
you have to strip the electron away so
you have the soup
right uh using a vacuum
uh where some of the atoms you stripped
the electron from them the outer
electron the valence electron you
stripped it out of them
you have to strip strip what does it
mean strip is a verb
strip is a verb you gotta pull verb
you gotta take away verb okay there's
motion
so you're going to have an atom you're
going to remove remove is an at is a
verb
you're going to remove an electron on
some of them
and this soup some are ionized some are
not
the soup we call plasma so what is
plasma
plasma is the stripping
okay stripping of electrons of some
atoms
it's a dynamic concept there is no
physical stand-alone object you cannot
take a picture
of plasma because whatever you took a
picture of
is just atoms you know the
all the electrons recombined and
they went back to their valence bands
so there is no such thing as a snapshot
of plasma
that's why you that's why plasma is not
a physical object you can't take a
picture because you turned it into an
atom
that's what you did okay so no
plasma is a concept it's a dynamic
concept you should not say that
plasma did this and plasma did that not
in science maybe in religion
okay okay another fellow here he raises
another issue
i can get this thing um there okay uh
says
i don't think it's fair to compare
science to religion religion honestly
admits
that its domain is based on faith
actually
uh religion is opinion not faith
okay it's not an issue of faith at all
it's an issue of opinion and an issue of
belief
and faith in that sense is not in the
same way it means that you're going to
believe in something not that you have
faith in the sense that
that you trust that's not an issue of
the word faith is very ambiguous okay
it's belief
and opinion okay that you have a belief
on something it could be belief
that your wife slept with your neighbor
that's a religion
and that's part of religion belief and
and uh uh what is it
um
belief and i forgot the word okay
science started out claiming something
totally different but science ended up
talking about the big bang
which is unrepeatable uh and
non-observable
and non-verifiable again science has
nothing to do
with observing or with verifying okay
and that's where we get into trouble
because that's what everybody learned in
high school that science is about
observing and verifying and making
predictions
not not true science has nothing to do
with any of that
in science we have to explain you got to
explain something that
shows that you use your brain for
something that you understood
otherwise you know if you're just going
to observe gawk oh
you know look at something say i
observed
was that science you observed the chair
and you you did science
uh verifiable so you verified that means
you
you proved to yourself and proving to
yourself is science
no that's belief that's again belief
opinion that's the word i want
okay so no it's not an issue of faith
it's an issue really
belief is not faith exactly faith is a
little bit different
belief and opinion science is far more
dishonest in my humble opinion and yeah
you're talking about mathematical
physics not about science and in that
sense you're totally right yeah what can
i say
hit it right on the on the nose okay
another
issue paul says uh what
that which is that would surround the
object is also
object according to you okay
this implies that which surround the
vacuum is the vacuum
is also a an object because according to
you vacuum also is also an object
then there is uh no remain no
uh yes i think this was not so given
then there is no
nothing remaining that you can call
vacuum in other words he's saying
so why you talk about vacuum and not
vacuum
well i don't know where he got that he
misunderstood this completely i think
what he's saying is the following
let's illustrate it so we know what
we're talking about
in fact uh someone else asked a similar
question so let me put that first okay
and this
fella says along the same line says the
vacuum in between all that
isn't vacuum has a 3d shape in other
words between the earth and the moon
right
he's saying that what's between them is
a vacuum and has 3d shape
by your definition of vacuum right of
space
vacuum vacuum or space is an object
and no again let's put all this in the
right context okay
here it is
give me a second here uh
vacuum is not between objects okay
remember objects don't displace the
vacuum like a fish displaces water in an
ocean
okay vacuum is not 3d it has no shape
and the vacuum forms the backdrop that
allows us to
see objects you can't see the vacuum you
remove the object there
is no 3d object remaining behind which
is what this file is saying here okay
and here's a picture of the of what uh
the other
fellow was referring to okay here's
here's an object
and it's in space it's the only object
that god made okay so it's we only have
a single object in the universe we got
rid of god as well he became spirit
um and so the question this guy is the
first guy let me put him back up there
i think it's this fella here he says uh
he's saying that
uh that black stuff also has shape and
the only
reason he must be thinking that is that
because i put a square around it or a
rectangle around it
uh no i have to stop it somewhere
because space does not have
shape there is no end no surface no
perimeter
the space space uh
serves as backdrop to that object but if
we remove that object we don't have
shape
we don't have uh anything that has uh
you know a perimeter a surface but this
fellow
thinks that it has because i put a
square around the the black stuff
and so he's saying what surrounds that
well the only way we can answer
that question is if you can tell me what
surrounds the black stuff
and it goes on and on and on you can't
say well there's another object that
surrounds the black stuff then what
surrounds that
and what are you going to say thought
the 10th dimension
you know what are you going to say so no
uh
the black stuff doesn't have shape it's
not 3d it's not
occupied there is no location in that
sense
like a fish occupying water uh
you know the earth does not move space
aside when it goes around the sun you
know
there is no friction between earth and
nothing
which is what space is or not i guess
you could say
okay along the same lines definition of
object here we have
okay and the file says basic common
definition object noun
a material thing that can be seen and
touched
dimensional properties which has weight
in a three-dimensional locational
environment add them together and you
get object
a material thing that can be seen touch
that has three-dimensional properties
which has weight
in a three-dimensional locational
environment and therefore square is not
an object doesn't meet those conditions
shadow isn't and a vacuum
isn't okay what's the problem with the
definitions this
gentleman proposes here it is
okay uh why it fails fails miserably and
here it is all the uh
uh circular definition let me put it
over here so you can compare them
okay uh material is already a
synonym of the word object so you can't
use the word material to define object
you can't use the word thing to define
an object because
thing is what the word we're trying to
define uh
c is a verb and before you can do verbs
you have to have objects only objects
can do verbs can do motion
so you can't say c okay can't use that
in the or touch for that matter
in your definition because that requires
a second object
and besides that you require an
experiment you need to see or touch
the moon before you can call the moon an
object and
that's terrible for the blind guy
because the blind guy never sees the
moon
and yet the word moon represents an
object always
okay so yeah it fails on almost every
the first sentence you fail miserably on
almost every count it's not material
it's not a thing
uh you can't use the word c and you
can't use the word touch they're all
destroyed very easy to destroy your
definition
so now an object is that which has shape
until someone can come up with a better
mouse trap
okay and again uh we should not
confuse that with existence okay
okay next issue next question next
comment
see if we can get this thing up there
people asked us about
a couple hours ago uh you wrote we start
out with an assumption that challenges
quantum mechanics
all atoms in existence are physically
interconnected
and his argument is there this doesn't
really challenge uh quantum mechanics at
all
in fact non-locality is assumed in a
wide variety of
interpretations of quantum mechanics and
many experiments seem to point towards
non-locality being true well not
locality just means black magic
non-locality means you know it's uh
that you're gonna invoke spirits
black magic you're gonna say that
something from out there which you're
not going to identify for sure
certainly uh what was this fellow uh
boom i can't remember his name now
um yeah boom and he he
believed in this non-locality but see
the problem with non-locality is that
you're not identifying the object and
you're not identifying especially
the mediator i need a physical mechanism
i need to know how that non-local thing
affected this thing over here
tell me how by what physical mechanism
if it's
disconnected from the local thing
so non-locality is verbage it's a it's a
way of saying
uh you know i'm going to do this with
black magic i'm going to do action at a
distance
you know uh without any mediator that's
what non-locality means
that's why it's nonsense not no county
is a term that quantum
invented to explain stuff like tunneling
and
entanglement why because they say this
particle here affects that one over
there okay non-local right and how did
you do that
hocus pocus that's how they did it
because the only way
this particle can affect this particle
over here this
here let me do it here like this the
only way this particle can affect
this particle over here from a distance
if there's something in between them
like for example this string here okay
then you can explain it but if you have
this situation how does this one
in any way affect this one if there's no
contact no physical contact between them
and that's the problem with non-locality
nando county also means the same thing
means that you're gonna
have action at a distance without
mediators so yeah quantum mechanics says
oh non-locality that's nonsense that's
idiocy
there's no rationality whatsoever now in
london not locality
okay another issue another question and
here it is
file says objects must have location
if you only had one thing in the
universe you wouldn't have an object
well yeah i mean again this vowel
confuses um
existence with object and that's the
problem that's been throughout history
okay everybody's confused object with
existence immediately when they get to
the word object they immediately go into
the word exist whether it exists or not
and that's where this process says it
must have location now objects don't
have to have location it's not a
property
an intrinsic property of objects okay
and here's an example okay i hope you
like my examples
uh follows his name is god he's the only
object in the universe
well he doesn't exist because so far he
doesn't have location
he doesn't have location with respect to
the black stuff the black stuff only
gives them shape or allows them to have
shape because we can see the backdrop
there
and so god is an object but this god
doesn't exist
if this god wants to exist he's better
make something real quick
unless he has location distance with
respect to other objects according to
the definition of exist
this god does not exist he only has
shape he only
he's only an object so far if god wants
to exist he better have location he
better create something real quick
okay and here's a definition just so
we put it in the right context okay
exists physical presence what does that
mean it means that physical part means
an object
and loca and presence means location
okay so that's what the word exists
means
object plus location what is an object
that which has shape
what is location the set of distances
what is the
distance was the separation between the
tree and god
and the rock and god and so on
okay we do not use any of the senses to
define exist or object okay we do not
see
touch smell or any of those we just
define
and these uh definitions are all
objective you can use them consistently
they are scientific
okay so yeah if god wants to exist he
had better make something real quick he
better make a rock he better make a
tree a chair or whatever you know then
he exists because now he has
distance with respect to these objects
now he exists
if god is alone so far he's only an
object so yeah you don't need to have
location
in order to be an object right
it's people who don't know the
difference between or don't understand
the difference between
object and existence that make this air
and keep introducing location
in the definition of objects
okay and the last question here our last
issue fella says
they say the moon is moving away from
the earth but if the earth has a
stronger gravity
should the moon fall on the earth one
day bill
well you said once that it would not
surprise you that the voyager probe
comes back
i never said that you explained it with
a
which pull in the direction of the earth
more strongly
now what i explain it's in the pioneer
video that i put out there you just got
to look up
pioneer anomaly okay and if you find a
video you'll
maybe just google it and that's
essentially it the summary of it you've
got the linear regime
okay so once you escape the earth the
earth yeah the solar system i was going
to say
uh you get this bird speak okay because
the ropes
are connected to the other star in this
case
the example is alpha centauri okay the
closest star 4.3 light years away
can you form that bird speak there and
what is that
well it's all the ropes connected to the
other star
now the star now you know one thing you
got to keep in mind my sons always
raised this issue and i had to correct
them okay
you have a son you know like uh let's
put a circle here
let me move this aside for a second you
can see better
yeah you got a circle right and you say
well from
this circle top of the circle to the
other star
it also has a top you know you got an
atom connected
one rope connecting those two atoms but
there's only one atom on the
very outer edge of both the sun and
alpha centauri only one atom out there
maybe you know
so there's only one rope connecting them
how many ropes are connecting from here
all the way to all the other atoms well
hopefully a lot more
and so the coaxial in the linear regime
goes through the center that's where
most of the ropes are going to be
in other words the ropes will tend to be
always closer to the center of the
linear regime
and what i said is that when the pioneer
probes try to leave the earth the solar
system
right uh they went through that burnt
speed
that means most of gravity is behind
them pulling them backwards
okay and so that's that's the what they
noticed with the
um uh with the uh
pioneer pro both the 10 and 11 that they
were decelerating
towards the sun so much so that
the calculations predicted that the
probes would be farther out and they
were closer in by the distance
of the earth to the moon you know there
was about one light second
uh that's how much difference there was
and they said why is there that
difference why is the
uh probe closer to the sun one light
second closer to the sun than it should
be
and so you know the guys who ran the uh
project were the guys who came up with
the answer after 10 years they oh we
found it it's some heat that's on the
front side of the
probes and that's why it's slowing it
down well we have a different
explanation we say that
the pros are entering the bird speak and
when they do
they go from the bird speed to the
linear regime
the farther they are out the more they
go into the linear regime
and again the coaxial goes through the
very center there are ropes on the
outside as well yeah outside of the
center
but um the more you get to uh the more
the farther out you get from the
sun the more you go through the center
of the coaxial that's where most
of the ropes are and so you get to that
situation you'll see at the end here
where you're essentially this is what
you're encountering
you're encountering all the ropes going
right through you
and going all the way to the sun you
know those that's where most of the
ropes will be there will be somebody
outside as well and you
even fewer at the farther out you go but
you're going through ropes because the
ropes are going through your atoms
and there's going to be a whole bunch of
ropes that are going to superimpose
and that's a can of worms which i'm not
even going to touch today because
we spent two hours speaking two of my
sons the other day on that issue
on how the ropes superimpose and how the
threads superimpose
and i can only give you as uh
food for thought but what we ended up
with
[Laughter]
and it's like this you have two threads
and
i can do it with a rubber band here
which is essentially how we did it with
them
you have you have one thread okay that's
the closed loop thread that
underlies all matter in the universe
right but just for the sake of argument
we're gonna put a second thread okay and
you can think of it as
the same thread maybe i should do it
with this one with this thread twist it
around
now under the rope model this goes right
through that one
okay thread goes through thread that's
the rope model but here's the million
dollar question
okay when the threads
at the moment they cross each other
right
at that point we'll call it a point okay
that location at that location that
point
does one thread cut across the other
or do they melt and become one
because it's got to do with the word
touch okay
what is touch touch is the absence of
space
there is no space between two objects
that
truly and genuinely touch each other
and here these two threads touched each
other meaning
they became one at that specific
location at that specific point
they became one and the issue here is
holy you had two and now they became one
yeah because that's the definition of
touch then when they came out of the
other side
they became two again so we have two
became one became
two because touch is zero
space meaning the two objects
became one okay so that's food for
thought it's got to do a lot with
language we got to define the word touch
for the purposes of science
and we can't define touch the way we do
it in ordinary speech saying well my
finger touched the table
what did you mean by that well we have
all this electromagnetic stuff fields
that touch each other
no you need to define the word touch in
the absolute sense
what do we mean by the word touch so
that we can use it consistently
the definition is zero space two objects
have become
one with that i'll see you next time